لم تكت شراره الاشتباكات الاولى تندلع بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في منطقه
المدينه الرياضيه الجنوبيه العاصمه
الخرطوم حتى انتقل مشهد القتال السريعا
الى مطار الخرطوم الدولي لتتحول السيطره
عليه الى اولويه قصوى لطرفي الصراع يقع
المطار الذي يعد اكبر مطارات البلاد في
قلب العاصمه الخرطوم وهو المقر الرئيسي
ومركز عمليات الخطوط الجويه السودانيه
ويشكل منفذا لمرور نحو 95% من حركه
الطيران الخارجيه ويلاصق الصوره الجنوبي
لمقر القياده العامه للجيش الذي يشهد
بدوره اشتباكات متواصله بين الجيش والدعم
السريع ورغم ان مطار الخرطوم يعد مطار
مدنيا فان هناك قاعده جويه كبيره ملحقه به
يربط فيها سرب من الطائرات الحربيه اضافه
الى تمركز دائم من الجيش
تسببت الاشتباكات التي شهدتها ارض المطار
بتعليق الرحلات الداخليه والخارجيه كما
لحقت دمار بعض منشاته اضافه الى احتراق
طائرات مدنيه
الاشتباكات حاله كذلك دون وصول اي وسطاء
وفود دوليه من خارج السودان لمحاوله وقت
المعارك
ومع اقتراب نهايه الاسبوع الاول من اشتعال
القتال لا تزال المعلومات متضاربه بشان
الطرف الذي يسيطر فعليا على مطار الخرطوم
وما يغشاه كثير من السودانيين ان يتسبب
استمرار الاشتباكات هناك بالمزيد من
الدمار لبوابتهم الرئيسيه نحو العالم
[موسيقى]